what's up everyone my name is Jorden and
my name is Max and today we are here to
talk about crypto the 11th the newest
legend - apex legends and to do a brief
guide of his abilities his best
strategies people who can counter him in
best ways to counter other legends with
him so max you have spent a large amount
of time with crypto both during the
preview event as well as just playing
now live with him in the public servers
let's briefly just go over his abilities
before diving deeper into each ability
and what they can do sure
so the first ability he has is his
tactical which is his mainstay his drone
and this drone is deployable it does
take a little bit of time to start up
once it's out goes fairly quickly you
can go up and down using Crouch to go
down jump to go up the drone pings
enemies it's just main bread-and-butter
is to find enemies and ping them but it
can also do a couple other things as
well it opens crates so he can find
other loot you can't loot through the
drone we can't open the boxes you can
open doors so you can sometimes even
pair with your teammates like hey throw
a grenade as soon as the door opens
because there's an enemy behind it but
its best ability by far is to grab
banners mm-hmm and people haven't been
finding that out very quickly but it is
something that once you know it's very
very useful so if this situation comes
up where your teammates are just getting
slaughtered and then their banners come
up because their crates are on the floor
you usually just want to hang back for a
bit send the drone out grab the banners
and just dip out
I'm not giving up on them it's a very
safe situation because you know he's not
risking herself it's just a drone and
the best part about that is you can do
that outside the ring mm-hmm so the
drones didn't take any damage outside
the ring so if your friend dies out in
the ring the banner is up and you could
just go send the drone grab it come back
and revive that which is great awesome
and I've also been playing a little bit
with Krypto and I have noticed that like
the banners themselves change when
you're looking at them through the drone
like what exactly is that doing the kill
eater banners they are actually hackable
quote-unquote and the drone actually
shows you how many squads are in it's
200 meter radius from that area that
it's in so what I like to do I found my
own technique to it which is I like to
kind of fly my drone behind the banner
and park it up there and it within that
area that I know it's 200 meters which
is huge so it's a pretty wide range I
like to just kind of check in it once in
a while and see if there's any enemies
around because if you know that there's
somebody around the corner or at least
within their vicinity then you can kind
of prepare and plan or at least start
looking around if there's no enemies
then you can just freely move without
worrying about anything so that's his
tactical but what about his passive
ability cryptos passive is to relay the
information that he gets from his drone
ping to his teammates similar to
bloodhounds a pings enemies through
walls and through smoke as long as the
joint is locked onto them so I've seen
strategies where there's somebody
there's very strong on your team was a
very good shooter to kind of relay with
them and ping the enemies that you
really want to attack and make it easier
for them to win the fight
the ultimate does have a lot of uses his
EMP pulse this EMP is absolutely amazing
it actually might be one of the better
Ultimates in the game I prefer to call
it the bunker buster' because it really
is it goes through walls which can
destroy any it defenses it destroys all
traps it does 50 shield damage it stuns
all the enemies in the area and I know
people think of complaining about
yourself being hit and damaged by it and
your teammates being stunned by it but
not damaged by it
but that's the same rule every other
ultimate at the game no that's a yeah it
brought there has it for his old
yeah Gibraltar Bangalore you know you
hurt yourself and stun yourself if you
get hit by it so I don't know understand
why people are freaking out about that
but that's part of his kid you know if
it has a huge range and if you hit
yourself then you will get damaged and
you will stun yourself in that situation
where there's kind of a stalemate when
you know where they are that's the best
way to initiate the fight so you send in
the drone you do the EMP at that point
everybody on their team has to either a
and have to heal shield so or B they
have to fight with at least maximum of
white shield situation cuz they're gonna
have only 150 HP at most right have
purple shields gonna be done at 150 with
like a white shield situation and that's
great advantage for you so he's usually
holding the backline physically and
having a drone go forward to scout ahead
and because of that if your team is
getting in a fight you know very quickly
you're usually you know a little bit
behind and by the time you get there
they might be already dead so sometimes
it can be not beneficial to you you can
offset that with good drone use and
pinging them correctly and making sure
your teammates hit them really well and
again the EMP use is very very useful to
start the fight off with using that
because of his whole kit and all that
together he's not an aggressive
character at home he's very very passive
and if his Joan gets destroyed forget it
I mean he's pretty much useless he's
just a plain old Bob walking around he's
got no passive or no skill on his own
for 40 seconds when that joins destroyed
and has to respawn he's just a normal
dude he has nothing
says we have already said like Watson
and caustic there a no go against crypto
he just drops as you said one of his
bunker busters his EMP pulse and all of
their hard work is just gone so he's a
really good counter against them but
what about legends that can counter
crypto who are the best characters we're
taking on the hacker the only legend who
can directly counter an EMP specifically
is Wraith because she can void through
it mm-hmm and it's very easy to because
once you see the EMP go off you can't
stop it so as soon as you start seeing
the blue electrical signals coming out
you should like a second app that you do
Boyd you'll dodge the whole thing you
just walk away scot-free other
characters within that range who will
get rekt best counter for him is anybody
who's good getting really anybody who
destroys his drone first it's just gonna
make him useless right and at that point
because the drone only has one HP again
if you have good aiming just knock that
out in one shot then he's out of the
fight pretty much for a while there's
combinations you can sort of do as well
with a couple of Ultimates bangalore's
is kind of tough because it's such a
slow explosion outdoors but Gibraltar
and Krypto have a really good synergy
where you can alt them at the same time
so they'll be immediately stunned and
then they can't go anywhere they have at
maximum on your 50 shields and they're
being rained on by Gibraltar sold and so
if they're like especially like holed up
on the top of a tower or something or
there's no actual cover and they're just
sniping down on you just use those tools
and they just get utterly obliterated if
you want more tips about other apex
legends we have a whole video series of
every other legends there are ten other
videos that you can watch and other
articles on the legends that you can
also read and of course we'll be
continuing to cover apex legends so just
be on the lookout for more content as
the season progresses and we go into
future seasons
[Music]
you